si sa santé s'en tire donc un suivi
souffrait beaucoup qu'on ne parle jamais
des femmes abusées et depuis que le pape
a parlé je vais mieux je vais beaucoup
mieux même c'est incroyable je
m'attendais pas à ça c'est comme si un
énorme couvercle se soulevait un
couvertes dans lequel moi aussi j'étais
quelque part enfermé alors je pense
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de chemin à
faire pour que les femmes se voient
reconnaître dans l'église la place qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être la leur
[Musique]
que l'on puisse me priver de ma chasteté
cela m'était inconcevable en plus il
s'agissait d'un prêtre qui avait fait le
même voeu de chasteté que moi
[Musique]
je pense particulièrement aux femmes qui
ont convié au câble dans le silence
quelles ont été abusés sexuellement
vertement je n'avais pas vraiment de
mots pourra parler et je n'avais même
pas le sentiment que j'aurais dû en
parler maintenant j'utilise le mot viol
comme on dénonce un prêt à temps
dénoncent aussi l'église donc si on aime
l'église c'est difficile d'aller jusqu'à
jusqu'à dire voilà ce que un de vos
prêts de fait
[Musique]
c'est une vie de souffrance elles disent
je suis complètement détruite de la tête
aux pieds
donc elles sont dans une situation de
culpabilité terrible d'abord par la
transgression ici c'est l'abus et puis
en plus savoir que dans leurs seins la
vie a été détruite
il y a une vie est un droit qu'elle
porte
aujourd'hui il ya une opinion publique
sur la pédophilie mais y'a pas d'opinion
publique sur la question d'abus sexuels
des religieuses par des prêtres il n'ya
pas d'opinion publique elle est à
construire elle est à faire